[Music]
and too good to be true loose submitted
by shrimp chips once again a great name
a couple of charged with theft after
spending most of an accidental deposit
to their accounts you know see I think I
hate stories like this because like
that's just some regular people shoot if
you wake up with 10k in your bank
account that's just negative tendencies
I'm gonna spin that [ __ ] I ask no
questions
oh don't you have a tummy nothing I'm
spending it until it's long not going to
the bank and telling them excuse me I
think you made a mistake you know charge
me with a crime charge above level made
mistake yeah you just feel like Santa
does exist I'm telling you man it's a
miracle I prayed for this exact that
would be like Oh God I will say dude if
it was like some crazy real money like a
million bucks or something I'm like what
can I do I'm doing the race right Mexico
like I'm out of here
they would think that you're involved in
the fraud but if it was my bank account
I don't think I'd do it it has to be a
bag full of cash untraceable kinda just
shows up in my living room now yeah but
then it's like that No Country for Old
Men [ __ ] [ __ ] we be contradicting
ourselves though because even in the
Constitution or what they say possession
is 9/10 of the law that's just in my
account it is mine okay how it got there
I don't that's mine
oh but now you say Oh Suze it was a
mistake now I can be charged with what
happened to the other bank [ __ ]
what's-his-name's is like you show me in
the Constitution where it says you've
attacked me and so for hot girls in my
living room yeah that's mine
possession is 9/10 of the law all I
gotta do is invite them you have 9/10 of
them okay 9/10 yeah that's pretty much a
hundred percent it's almost a percent of
that fan who's in your living room yeah
okay no no hookers for the time being
thank you Tim okay well you don't you're
not owning you're renting
that's a rental it's a lease yeah yeah
okay but your rental
sylia property like a certain extent
right it's still yours true for the time
being I'm going with this anyway go rent
a hooker Tift that's what is trying to
say Jeff wants to run the hooker in
Africa actually yeah we were just
talking about the sidebar whole thing
anyway
so this couple they just wanted to beat
her up like I'm gonna rent a hooker to
go shopping probably just a doctor but
anyway so okay this couple they woke up
one morning and they found a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars in the bank
account and they they spent a hundred
thousand of it I'd one day two and a
half weeks oh my god they knew what it
was minute to figure it out knew and I
would have done that day I would have
went and took a hundred and nineteen
thousand of it out and just dipped I
would have left that other thousand in
there and the bank would have figured it
out no yeah yeah I don't know how far I
can really be on the land Bitcoin maybe
they're still gonna come after you cuz
it's in your account and it disappeared
I do yet yeah well I mean that's what
happen to these people so yeah I mean
what the [ __ ] do they think that just
shows you what it's like to be broke
when you broke and then you get some
money it's not you know when people get
their tax money because you've been
broke like you'll spin that [ __ ] they
call it mad money is what they call
merged it on a camper a Chevy a racecar
fifteen thousand dollars to friends who
needed money
Oh at least they're not sure it's what
they're saying this is why people who
win the lottery go broke and I can't
tell anyone up and don't do anything
about a regular car they were like wait
no we need a camper - they're like wait
if we could buy two cars we should get a
racecar
why was that all that they were trying
to get was vehicles they want to drive
away don't want nothing else just call
it
like you do the whole universal basic
income thing I'm all like ah they're not
gonna spend that money when it's
inflation it'll be immediately
inflationary on the entire model curse
you get a ton of [ __ ] money if you
already don't know how to manage that
money you're gonna spend it on stupid
[ __ ] you were already brought up because
I would if I want a lot I would
immediately had a circus come to town
just for me they're my friends they had
a thousand one hundred and twenty-one
dollars in their account before they got
this money I would have an elephant
parade wait just because so much money
then so they they had $1,000 to the man
no that's it what are they gonna do to
get that money banned about depreciating
assets [ __ ] the worst kind to campers
yeah you can't do worse than camps are
near water that's why I didn't buy a
boat wait what's what state is is in the
dumbest state in America rested yeah so
I could have bought horses
[Music]
now they even got bail money or lawyer
mother because you could make money with
horses yeah keep collecting
transportation beautiful boats cars tank
I wanna take some roller skates you
could buy a tank for 40 grand what the
guns defunct but you could drive around
with it not the freeways too slow yeah
you could go on the side roads you
really freak some neighbors out
that is reck all the roads where it's
just rented a bought a tank like the
gangs and then they were okay that would
be crazy
that's a real drive-by yeah get pulled
over immediately and you can't get away
you're not getting away drive over the
cop car that's it we shouldn't give them
any ideas though these tanks we're gonna
get $40,000 from this liquor store from
five liquor stores they have a whole
plan we're gonna get a tank yeah and
they were protected I want a boat with a
machine gun on it why shoot the rapist
dolphins
no rape dolphins [ __ ] that or a
helicopter with the machine gun just
anything with a machine gun are they
doing time - yeah so they face three
felony charges of receiving stolen
property they've also said that they are
responsible for returning all the funds
and there was this withdrawal that
resulted in one hundred and seven
thousand four hundred and seven sixteen
dollars in overdraft fees now that's the
real crime we have some nerves yeah they
gave you that money and then they're
like we don't charge you a hundred
thousand [ __ ] up yeah in overdraft
they did the bank get penalized at all
that's crocheting [ __ ] no but yeah I
used to work at a bank and it was
highway robbery but I can and when you
really think about the last day but I
don't have the money in my account and I
over spend it I charge in my car that
you let me do why would you think the
solution is charge me more money that I
already don't have yeah it's like
arresting and charging people take what
now you're charging me $35 per for
dipping
it's a long game they're trying to [ __ ]
your credit score up so the 19 hot cha
retire interest rates later why would
they let you drive over like overdrive
that doesn't make any sense because the
car should go like block line yeah
that's what [ __ ] when I signed up for
my debit card like in college like the
guy over the phone tried to get me to
sign up for like oh we can have
overdraft protection I'm like dude just
[ __ ] deny my card is like well you're
not being responsible [ __ ] you you're
not being responsible you just let me
know money just deny the [ __ ] charge
I don't give a [ __ ] that's why I use
credit cards not debit cards well at the
time I had like nothing really said I
got bad credit so I can't get a credit
card
cuz you over John I used to work I used
to work for Bank guys working with small
business department it was so trap I
sometimes like when people would have
their cars like say you overdo your
accountants say like you have $1,000 in
account and then you spent it off but
there's still then use your car so you
just do seven charges that might equal
up to $20.00 in total of those charges
they're gonna charge you thirty-five
dollars for each time you did that
exactly so this is ten times and it only
costs $25 that's still 300 dollars I
wouldn't you can't call them and say
[ __ ] you take that [ __ ] off right now no
we're just charges of poor people tax
just like a [ __ ] street-sweeping and
all his [ __ ] depends on how you get
though and what bank you're with because
that wouldn't that happened to me when I
was hella broke and like it was a bunch
of charges it was like that and they
charged and I went in there and I just
cried I was like I did they cleared it
fun yeah because they're like first of
all it was and they were like you've
never been late before I've never
overdrafted and so they think I gave you
good that's what I do I call all the
time if I before automatic payment
settings were on I would always forget
but then I'm like I always pay my [ __ ]
I'm just a day or two late just cut it
out and then don't be like I yeah I see
a nicer first time for me and then after
I'm like we can't be like every month no
no yeah yeah no like in the whole
history of me having that account
yeah if I've had it for like ten years
one person says no you hang up and you
call again until someone says yes I'm
[ __ ] persistent man one time I don't
[ __ ] around trying to buy the house I
charged a dollar fifty on my pr1 card
because like they were having some sale
and I was like oh I haven't used this
card and I want to like you know build
my credit or whatever and so I add ollar
50 for a placement and they don't
have Auto payments and I forgot that
they didn't have Auto payments and so
it's [ __ ] mic score right when we were
trying to get it a loan I went ballistic
I called and the lady didn't give a [ __ ]
she was like well I'm sorry there's not
now Mike I know and then I hung up on
her and I crazy like I just and a nice
lady picked up and she was like an older
lady you could tell and she was like oh
I'm so sorry this hand this is she's
like unfortunately the only time we
could ever take this away is if you were
trying to buy a house or did it like and
she was like okay and then she she gave
it back dollar 50 was going to destroy
everything I had built for like five
dollars if you don't like the person
gonna call back they have a lot of
people back there yeah the first girl
almost took joy out of not giving it to
me she's like well I'm sorry there you
should are at that details now you try
to get him in trouble
just just try to get them kept caught
and then go is your manager here mm-hmm
you got to do the whole Susan [ __ ] yeah
you gotta do that so could you hate
women you catch him you know who's
actually good with that case he's dead
he's amazing
he's a [ __ ] magician when it comes to
let me talk to the [ __ ] manager
really yeah I saw him talk to the
[ __ ] car rental guy and then he was
talking to him and he basically I forgot
what he did exactly but he got him mad
and he acted very unprofessionally so
then the so because of that he goes
caught you where's your manager at the
manager comes in you know this is
exactly what your employee said whatever
whatever whatever was like what is he
[ __ ] damn that's crazy I'm not that
confrontational huh what do you end up
getting I forgot put on the tee you're
like this is why KC's dad's the man he
didn't care about the end he just you
like that moment the man the
how he catches them but Casey what did
he do what did he do I forgot we
remember better a banner ring I know
he's got some how about deals guy you
have a balls the deals guy don't know I
don't I don't care about I care about
results I don't care about pride so [ __ ]
it like I don't want a sorry give me a
better grade or something you don't care
about pride
[Music]
[Music]